we've been using Apple's new 2019
MacBook Air for about a week and we can
say that it basically feels the same as
last year's model but unlike last year
quite a few things have changed that
will greatly impact your buying decision
if you've seen our recent which MacBook
should you buy in 2019 video you
probably already know that the new base
13-inch MacBook Pro is the king of value
when it comes to performance
being much faster than the MacBook Air
and offering basically twice as much
performance per dollar so in the case
that you really want the most
performance you can get you should
obviously just buy the MacBook Pro
instead but what if you don't really
care that much about performance and
what if you value other things instead
like battery life typing experience and
saving a couple hundred bucks that's the
case for a lot of people out there for
people who just need a basic reliable
and premium laptop to students writers
or programmers and yes we did just
release a brand new video talking about
how it actually makes sense for some
people to buy an iPad pro over a MacBook
Air but if you're digging the
traditional laptop field and you need
Mac OS the air still makes a lot of
sense to buy despite being the only
macbook in apple's 2019 lineup with a
dual-core processor and in the real
world unless you're doing power
demanding productivity tasks the MacBook
Air is still fast enough for a lot of
people for example people have been
using dual-core MacBook Airs for
programming and apps like Xcode for
years despite being much slower than the
MacBook Pros sure it won't get the job
done as quickly but it still gets it
done and for productivity work like
programming the MacBook Pros brighter
and more color accurate display doesn't
really matter on the plus side the
MacBook Air it does get true total
technology this year a feature which
automatically adjusts the white balance
of the display to match the environment
you're in so if you're in a very warm
lit dark room the screen won't blast you
with a bunch of distracting blue light
this is a really great feature
especially for people who spend a lot of
time typing on their Mac books and for
typing the MacBook Air is the best you
can get this year that's mainly due to
the fact that the keyboard actually
slopes downward towards the front edge
which makes typing a lot more
comfortable compared to the flat and
straight edged MacBook Pro and here's
where the drama comes in
apples butterfly keyboard is still
equipped on this MacBook and the
butterfly keyboard is known for having
dead or stuck key issues and it's a
major reason why people think twice
about buying it but is this a major deal
we don't think so
for a few reasons let's talk about our
sponsor Squarespace it's never been so
easy to create your own website there's
a huge variety of templates to choose
from and it's so easy that I personally
created this business site in no time
just click to add basically anything
from image galleries two buttons in
e-commerce products and then you can
easily arrange them so make it with
Squarespace checkout squarespace.com for
a free trial and when you're ready to
launch go to Squarespace comm slash Mac
stack to save 10% off your first
purchase of a website or domain we've
been using and testing apples butterfly
keyboard equipped Mac books ever since
the original 2015 retina MacBook and so
far out of around 30 Mac books we've
tested with five of them being long-term
we've only had issues with one macbook
and that's the original 2015 12 inch
retina other than that we've experienced
none of the issues at all and the best
part about the 2019 MacBook Air is that
it features Apple's fourth generation
butterfly keys with new materials that
are supposed to be more reliable this
version of the keys has been on the
market for around two months and so far
we haven't heard of a single report of
keyboard issues on the 2019 Mac books so
we're now pretty confident that if you
buy a 2019 MacBook Air you probably
won't experience any issues and just to
give you peace of mind
Apple is giving you a free four year
keyboard replacement warranty on any new
MacBook and to be completely honest if
your keyboard is affected it'll probably
happen within the first four years so I
probably wouldn't worry about it at all
now here's something great about the
MacBook Air it's now the only new
MacBook that comes with function keys so
if you absolutely hate the touch bar
that now comes on every map of Bro you
can go with the MacBook Air instead and
as a bonus you still get the touch ID
sensor which is really convenient for
logging in and not having to answer your
password every time Mac OS asks you for
it and while the trackpad is a bit
smaller than the one on the pro it's
still the same industry-leading force
touch trackpad that's perhaps one of the
biggest advantages over Windows lab
it's seriously the best trackpad you can
get on top of that if you value battery
life the MacBook Air gets the most
battery life out of any math book PC Mag
show that it ran for 20 hours in their
battery life test about an hour and a
half longer than the pro and completely
wiping the floor with other Windows
laptops we tested the speaker's various
times and we found that they're actually
pretty great especially compared to a
lot of Windows laptops out there now
they're not as busy as the MacBook Pro
speakers but they're definitely good
enough to binge watch your favorite show
on Netflix
so with the MacBook Air you get a very
comfortable typing experience standard
function keys really good speakers
top-of-the-line battery life a decent
display the excellent trackpad and
reliable Mac OS software all for eleven
hundred dollars or a thousand dollars
with a student discount so how the heck
was Apple able to drop the price by $100
this year for a great laptop like this
well here's where the bad news comes in
while testing storage speeds of the new
MacBook Air we saw that they've become
quite a bit slower compared to SSDs from
2018 even a 512 gigabyte model was
limited to around 1,300 megabytes per
second read and write speeds now is this
a big deal actually I don't think so
yes it does suck that storage speeds are
slower but they're still just as fast or
faster than most Windows laptops and for
the people this MacBook is meant for
like students writers programmers and
common people the speeds are actually
more than fast enough you really only
need faster storage speeds for working
with productivity apps like Photoshop
Lightroom and Final Cut Pro and if
you're doing that you should be buying a
MacBook Pro anyway so no I don't think
the slower storage speeds are a big deal
at all
overall this is a great laptop it is
probably the best choice if you don't
need the extra performance and would
like to save a couple hundred bucks
however there is a third wheel that just
entered the market and that's the 2018
iPad pro loaded with Apple's upcoming
iPad OS software and I think it could
actually make sense for some
to choose that instead if you haven't
already seen that video definitely check
it out right there and if you enjoy this
review tap the like button click the
circle above to subscribe thanks for
watching and we'll see you in the next
video
[Music]